chuckle I'm 19 and my in my first year
of college ever since I was 12
I've dreamed about being a marine or
SEAL
I plan on joining up after college but I
just got diagnosed with epilepsy I only
have seizures in my sleep so I never
noticed them
I always thought of serving in the
military as a way that I would prove to
myself that I was a man and that it
would be it give my life a purpose now I
don't know what to do I hate the idea of
living some comfortable life where I
have a cozy nine-to-five job that I only
do for the money
I want something hard and meaningful
what should I do there's an infinite
number of options that you have so you
need to just pick one of those options
find a new career of that you think
looks cool and then go get after it
and you got to figure you want to you
don't want a nine-to-five job Cole
there's all kinds of jobs that aren't
nine-to-five you know whether it's
construction management construction or
gas oil or some kind of Public Safety
there's all kinds of things I don't know
if you can be a firefighter on if you
can be a cop if you have epilepsy I'm
not sure but there's all kinds of
different jobs and careers and there's
jobs that are hard and there's jobs that
are incredibly meaningful to our economy
here and the more you help our economy
here the more you help us have a
positive influence in the world so go
and figure out what job that you want to
do and go crush it and go you don't
build an empire and make a ton of money
and then if you want to great then you
can support some veterans causes and you
can give back that way
so so that's cool there's there's it's
always impressive to me we work with all
kinds of different companies a national
on front it's always so impressive to me
when I meet people from every possible
industry that you can imagine and
they're completely into their job they
are so into their job they're fighting
World War nine like they're that into it
you know they're run an Intel they'll
run an OP
they're driving down every dollar
matters everything that they're doing
they're so into it and it's awesome and
and this is everything this is every
different industry I see people like
that no not every person in every
industry is like that but if you find
something that you're interested is in
and you jump in there and that's gonna
be your vocation right now there's
another part to this that is kind of I
guess like in your head or whatever
that's like some kind of hard living
that's not that's not very difficult to
come up with right go start training
jiu-jitsu go start training some boxing
go start wrestling go do muy Thai go
start shooting go start lifting and
seeing how strong you can get and seen
how powerful you can get go learn to
hunt and learn to hike and learn to play
guitar you learn just learn a bunch of
stuff become a force to be reckoned with
and you know the bottom line is being a
seal or being a Marine does not prove
that you are a man there are plenty of
losers in both of those organizations
and so don't you don't need some label
to make you a man
that's not what makes you a man be your
own man go out and conquer your part of
the world
next question two questions I recently
attended an assessment for retraining
but say one more thing sorry when things
like this happen like when something
happens to me this is you want to hear
my weird superstitious view of the world
sure it's sort of it's sort of
reminiscent of everything happens for a
reason
you've heard that everyone's heard that
for me something like this when
something like this happens to me when
something happens in my life that I
didn't want to have happen or I didn't
expect to happen I get an unpleasant
surprise I look at it in a
like okay this is this is happening so
that's something else this is trying to
prevent something else from happening to
me that I would have been really
catastrophic I hurt my knee the other
day doing jiu-jitsu doing doing
wrestling and I you know I'm on my way
driving home I'm like you know what this
is preventing me from wrecking my
shoulder in two weeks or the next night
I was probably gonna wreck my shoulder
which is which is no a catastrophic
injury on my shoulder that's what was
about to happen to me and the powers
that be knew the only way to get me off
the mat was to hurt my knee bad enough
that it pulled me off the map for for a
couple weeks there's a boom there you go
here you go Jocko you're welcome yeah so
something like this this is an indicator
far as I'm concerned you have some
bigger and better thing that you need to
do some hey it wasn't this yeah that's
cool except it like right on say thank
you because there's people that they
it's not epilepsy that they have they
have something that debilitates them
from doing even things that you are
capable of doing so be stoked that this
delivery came from wherever it comes
from whatever it is that you believe in
that this dis dis God this happened
because it's it's putting you on the
path I guess that's what I'm saying yeah
putting you on the path so who knows
what you're supposed to do but you're
supposed to do something because you're
not supposed to be a seal you're not
supposed to be a Marine if you were
supposed to be that that would have
happened it didn't happen it's not a bad
thing that means there's some other
doors gonna open up big yeah so that's
the way I always look at injuries like
that yeah the most positive way I can
look at injuries is hey I was going to
whatever I was gonna live like I was
gonna rip apart triple threat on my knee
in four days so I just got a little ding
to pull me off the mat so that doesn't
happen
yeah oh I needed rest here's what you
get boom
you're gonna get this yeah I'll have
those thoughts do some yes like it's
kind of like oh I'm safe from injury
because I'm already injured kind of
thing yes like there we go so weird
feeling yeah but that is true and yeah
and kind of like a lot of times too and
this is so good that that guy this guy
is he knows already I want to do
something Harding me a bra
I'm man how do you say old he was
nineteen nineteen man 1919 him yeah the
path raised totally on the path and you
know he's just discovering what doors he
wants to you know what doors are opening
all the doors are closed whatever you
know and he's disc up man when I was 19
yeah I didn't have no direction dude did
I ever have the thought of hey yeah I
want to do something hard and meaningful
did I ever have that thought hmm no I
did not have that thought ever waits or
something just but yeah man that's good
so I think he's in the game yeah yeah
there's no there's no label that makes
you a man
you do